okay on to Anderson Cooper the face of
CNN and a man who has traveled to more
than 70 countries covering the news so
we're in the world could he possibly go
when he wants to unwind and relax when
we have a look at his brand-new amazing
Brazilian hideaway we see a side of
Anderson that we rarely see on the news
we see him as relaxing at home reading a
book in a hammock really decompressing
from the world Anderson also poses with
his longtime partner Benjamin Missoni
and two friendly neighbor dogs it's like
that in the small seaside village of
trancoso Brazil where homes are
traditionally named after their owners
theirs is Casa Anderson Anderson first
visited trancoso with his partner
Benjamin and their friend Andy Cohen and
he tells me that the very first day he
was there he started thinking about
making a home for himself there the
globe-trotting reporter told
Architectural Digest out today quote
I've worked in 70 countries and traveled
to even more and I've never seen
anything like trancoso the estate
features four buildings and the date
course simple and unpretentious a mix of
vintage finds and pieces crafted by
local artisans and the lush rainforest
comes right up to the edge of the pool
it all looks like the perfect place to
unwind the only problem Anderson's
hardly ever there Anderson confessed
that he doesn't get there as often as
he'd like maybe three weeks a year and a
few weekends but he says that just
knowing that the place is there and that
he can get to it makes him happy he
keeps a picture of the property in his
office here at CNN it's a spectacular
home but no easy journey to get there
it's 14 hours of flight time from New
York City then a long car ride so that
could explain why Anderson only gets
there a few times
you